speaking of silly drivel here's gay pete
now gabe pete of course as you know is
the transportation secretary never had
any experience doing transportation he
was the mayor of south bend indiana very
small town not it's unclear to me
whether he had a car even uh he did once
get caught they wanted a video of him
riding a bike and then he of course got
caught because they put him in a truck
with the bike and then they took him
somewhere and then he got on the bike
but they wanted to make it seem like
he's a real big biker because he's a
transportation guy he's completely inept
he took a few months off for paternity
leave while all of the
supply chain stuff was going down um he
is he is nothing he is just a suit with
nothing in it he is pretending he speaks
with the same affect as barack obama i
mean they're just training him he's the
perfect he's sort of like a young obama
a young
biden it's just like you're a suit
that's part of the machine you stand for
nothing but you always say the thing
that the machine wants you to say but
then we have a real
congressman this is thomas massey of
kentucky and he's grilling gay pete on
what's going on here with all this
electric car nonsense the average
household uses 17 percent of their
electricity for air conditioning
and
that would mean the average household
uses
1
870 kilowatt hours per year for air
conditioning if that average household
plugged in electric cars
do you know how much more electricity
they would use in comparison to the air
conditioning that air conditions their
whole house no but again i would
emphasize it will let me help you let me
help you with that first before we go on
because the numbers are important it
would take four times as much
electricity to charge the average
households cars as the average household
uses on air conditioning do you think
that could be so if we reach the goal by
2030 that biden has of a 50 adoption
instead of 100 adoption that means the
average household would use twice as
much electricity charging
one of their cars as they would use for
all of the air conditioning that they
use for the entire year do you think
this could contribute to
rolling uh blackouts and brownouts in
areas of the country where air
conditioning is basically considered
essential not if we prepare look the
fact that people who have electric
vehicles are going to use more
electricity can't be a reason to give up
the idea that america is inferior to the
other countries that have figured this
out just doesn't sit well with us in
administration and that's why
i have a better grid
pete is so deeply inauthentic even his
accent feels fake right everything about
him feels fake but thomas massey you
might be watching thomas maxine go dave
you're showing me a congressman from
kentucky he must be backwards he must
power his car with moonshine he's from
the south
uh actually thomas massey has owned an
electric vehicle for nearly 10 years and
i have the image on my phone right here
you can google it yourself he turned a
tesla model s battery into a home power
system for himself because i think he's
also an electric engineer if i'm not
mistaken okay so this is a guy who
believes in electric energy this is not
some anti-technology person this is not
some crazed fossil fuel lobbyist okay
this is a guy who believes in actual
science and all of those things but what
he's saying is you government stooges
gay pete don't know what you're doing
you're telling people they're going to
save money but they're actually not
going to save money and i have the
evidence right here and pete basically
says
yeah you know a certain amount of pain
and if you just give us enough power
we'll figure out how to deal with it uh
and here's pete going even a little bit
deeper this is a while back but it's
been getting the it's been making the
rounds again over the last couple days
uh basically admitting that the pain
related to all of this is actually the
point of course the more pain we are all
experiencing from the high price price
of gas the more benefit there is for
those who can access electric vehicles
did he just say that i think we might
have to show that again because that
would be an odd thing for a government
official to say we're intentionally
hurting you people that seems odd of
course the more pain we are all
experiencing from the high price price
of gas the more benefit there is for
those who can access electric vehicles
do
you
get it yet
the pain is the point when they tell you
that it is putin's price hike it is a
lie
they are intentionally
increasing the price of gas not going to
our reserves not unleashing american
energy properly because they want the
price to be high and why do they want
the price to be high so that you will
get off that car and you will get one of
their electric vehicles now i am not
against electric vehicles i have a tesla
it's freaking awesome i drove us all
yesterday to the gun range was it fun
being back there you guys were watching
netflix there's a little little tv
screen back there pretty great
um i only let them watch the kids shows
by the way what were you watching i was
uh
paw patrol you love that paw patrol um
i'm not against electric vehicles the
tesla is absolutely awesome although uh
tesla which obviously does get some
government subsidies too is not always
on the list of uh companies that the
government really wants to help because
the biden administration obviously does
not love elon musk that's a separate
issue altogether this has nothing to do
with whether electric vehicles are good
or bad the point is the government is
actively telling you
because 90 of americans can't afford an
electric vehicle right they just can't
and things things change over time
remember remember what it was 15 years
ago if you were buying a 42 inch flat
screen tv i remember i bought my first
samsung 42 inch flat screen tv i must
have bought it around 2008 something
like that i remember it cost 2 500 i had
virtually no money i bought it on a pc
richards uh payment plan which it ended
up costing me like 5 000 bucks because
of all the interest i racked up on that
stupid thing but the point is things
cost a lot and then over so rich people
afford them first right vcrs used to
cost a lot
dvd players blu-ray players whatever
things cost a lot at first a certain
amount of more wealthy people get them
that then allows more of them to be made
the costs go down this is basic
economics and then more people can
afford it what they are doing is
artificially gaming the system right now
and saying it doesn't matter whether you
can afford it or not we are going to
hurt the hell out of you and what's
interesting even more interesting about
it is so they're hurting the hell out of
you by making you pay more for gas as if
suddenly you'll just magically be like
oh you know what
sure i i have this hyundai and you know
it's only five years old but the gas is
so much and i really can't afford
anything else but but pete gay pete
wants me to get an electric car and i'm
gonna go do it cause he gave pete we
have a meme of gay pete
you can't afford eight dollar a gallon
gasoline then buy a 50 000 car you
[ __ ] idiot i love that one i love
that one so put the smile on that one
they just really nailed that one put
that back up for a sec
i mean it's just this is what it is this
is the government we are hurting you we
smile this i am this is my barack obama
sleeves up no jacket pose and buy a car
because yes you are a [ __ ] idiot